[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a 4 ans
jour pour jour j'ai eu un accident de
parachutisme
qui m'a coûté la vie vous avez bien
entendu j'ai eu un accident de
parachutisme qui m'a coûté la vie
après mon impact au sol quand les
premiers secours arrivent ils évaluent
mon score de Glasgow à 4 alors pour tous
ceux qui comme moi n'ont entendu score
de Glasgow que dans les séries urgences
Grey's Anatomy c'est l'ensemble des
stratégies que décide les premiers
secours afin de maintenir les fonctions
vitales d'un patient plus le score eva
est moins c'est bon moi avec un score de
4 j'ai 87% de chance de mourir
9 chances sur 10 d'y rester
mon pronostic vital est donc
sérieusement engagé je plonge dans le
coma mon corps est brisé enfin plusieurs
os de mon corps sont brisés mais sens
tels que ma vue mon audition mes
articulations mais ligaments et j'en
passe tout ça et endommagé
des mois disparaissent de mes souvenirs
des moments que j'ai vécu pour lesquels
j'ai des choses que j'ai écrites des
photos et des histoires que l'on me
raconte mais dont je n'ai plus aucun
souvenir ça a disparu
des zones de mon cerveau sont détruites
pour toujours
je touche le fond comme jamais
pendant
plus de 2 ans et demi
pendant plus de deux ans et demi à
chaque respiration
à chaque respiration j'ai des pensées
des sensations des émotions
des ressentis des idées et
pouvant table il y a
de la peur
de l'incompréhension
du doute
de la frustration
de l'impuissance
de l'impatience
de la colère
de la rage
de la tristesse
de la solitude
et du désespoir
je touche que fond comme jamais
je vais mettre fin à mes jours à quoi
bon rester en vie si c'est pour souffrir
en permanence en tant crevé je suis
complètement ravagé et mon entourage
avec moi par un trouble de stress post
traumatique
je suis Dimitri Dimitri ils ont pas haut
et ce que je viens de vous raconter est
à l'origine de ma renaissance
il est possible à la suite d'une épreuve
particulièrement destructrice
de vivre des changements positifs et ces
changements sont tout aussi bien
cognitifs et émotionnel et ils ont des
répercussions dans la vraie vie
j'ai poussé un grand ouf de soulagement
vous pouvez pas imaginer comment ça m'a
soulagé parce que je pensais que j'étais
devenu fou oui car certains changements
décrit dans cette approche commencer
déjà à se matérialiser par exemple
quand j'ai retrouvé mes esprits après
être sorti du coma de façon totalement
spontanée je ne voyais plus qu'elle
était l'intérêt pour moi de poursuivre
ma carrière dans le monde d'avant ce qui
était une aberration parce que j'en
avais toujours arrivé
parce qu'en fait ce que j'apprends c'est
que ce phénomène de croissance
post-traumatique est un phénomène
naturel c'est quelque chose qui se
déclenche tout seul automatiquement
par contre si ce phénomène est autonome
il n'est pas systématique c'est-à-dire
que tout comme tous ceux qui traversent
un événement difficile ne sont pas
touchés par un stress post traumatique
et bien toutes les personnes qui
traversent une épreuve destructrice ne
connaîtront pas une période de
croissance post traumatique mais à ce
stade là moi ça ne suffisait c'était la
preuve dont j'avais besoin
renaître de ses cendres après une
épreuve cataclysmique c'est possible
le phénix n'est pas un mythe le phénix
il lui en chacun de nous alors le
préparateur mental est le coach en
performance que je suis a décidé
d'initier lui-même sa propre Renaissance
j'ai décidé de réveiller mon petit
oiseau de feu
et de piloter ma reconstruction
découvrir le travail de tous ces
chercheurs
m'a permis de métaboliser toute ma
souffrance
pour qu'elle change ma vie au mieux
alors vous imaginez que une processus
une période de croissance une période de
développement après un trauma prend du
temps
c'est quelque chose qui est en quelque
sorte un chemin initiatique qui peut
prendre longtemps voire très longtemps
ma présence dans ce rond rouge 4 ans
après mon accident en est une
illustration
mais avant de vous en dire davantage sur
comment cette initié ma renaissance il
faut que je vous en dise davantage sur
l'homme que j'étais avant
alors l'homme que j'étais avant
l'accident j'ai forcément vous parler du
petit Dimitri le petit Dimitri a grandi
avec l'idée que s'il voulait être un
homme bien si vous voulez avoir la
chance de trouver l'amour et peut-être
d'être heureux ça passait impérativement
par la réussite avoir du succès était
donc vital pour moi
et ça a commencé très jeune il me
fallait de bonnes notes
ensuite il fallait de bonnes études et
puis un bon travail et oui pour avoir un
bon salaire
avec un bon poste et oui
il fallait pouvoir avoir un beau costume
une belle cravate
une belle montre
une belle voiture
le petit Dimitri donc assimile tout
naturellement qui il est à sa carrière
je suis mon travail et mon travail c'est
moi nous ne formons qu'une seule et même
entité
du coup le petit Dimitri a aussi grandi
avec le besoin d'être hyper performant
bah oui puisque dans ma réalité si je
voulais avoir la chance d'être heureux
ça passait impérativement par le fait de
progresser d'évoluer dans la hiérarchie
j'ai donc
tout consacrer à mon travail j'ai
délaissé mes loisirs j'ai dévissé mes
amis j'ai délaissé ma famille
et j'ai très souvent des risques ma
femme pour le travail
avec mon accident tout ceci par
en mille morceaux
mon corps est brisé
ma vie est brisée
il faut que je me reconstruise mais
croyance mais certitude mes convictions
mes idéaux tout ça est à rebâtir il y a
clairement un avant et un après alors
justement dans le après maintenant
comment est-ce que c'est initié ma
renaissance et bien avec le recul je me
rends compte qu'elle a commencé assez
tôt des monospitalisation en fait en
améliorant mes relations mes rapports
avec les autres alors j'ai toujours eu
de la facilité pour aller au devant des
autres quand il était question d'aborder
des sujets professionnels parler de
travail de carrière de ma petite
réussite accessoirement ça allait très
bien mais ces masques sociaux se
fissurent et tombent alors que je suis à
l'hôpital entouré de tous ces survivants
qui comme moi ont vécu des choses
abominable là-bas je ne suis personne
je n'ai pas de titre
je n'ai pas de costume je n'ai pas de
cravate pas du travail est impossible
je n'ai qu'une envie c'est être avec ces
autres personnes et c'est tout partager
avec elle et c'est ce que je fais je
partage les parts de pizza et soda et
compote de pommes et des éclairs au
chocolat que me ramène mon épouse et
bien je les partage avec tous ces
survivants qui viennent de milieu
complètement différent qui viennent de
tous les horizons et qui m'enrichissent
énormément je prends beaucoup de plaisir
et ça perdure encore aujourd'hui mais je
décide donc de tomber l'armure de
l'homme fier qui réussit et je me livre
plus facilement
y compris sur des sujets personnels voir
un team qui ne me mettent pas du tout
mais alors pas du tout en avant je ne
suis plus dans cette vente permanente de
moi-même et mes rapports mes relations
sont beaucoup plus
authentiques et épanouissante
être avec tous ces survivants et bien ça
m'a donné la force ça m'a donné le
courage et ça m'a permis de réorienter
toute l'énergie de ma souffrance pour
que au lieu qu'elle me détruise de
l'intérieur elle me transforme alors par
contre
je tiens à dire que vivre une période de
croissance vivre une période de
développement après un trauma
n'est pas une partie de plaisir
au contraire c'est une période qui est
remplie de défis qui est plein de
challenge et mieux vaut être habitué et
à l'aise avec le changement et
particulièrement
efficace dans sa capacité d'adaptation
me livrer sur la période de la plus
sombre et la plus douloureuse de mon
histoire devant autant de personnes est
un des exemples
des challenges que la croissance
post-traumatique peut vous demander vous
amener à relever ou pas d'ailleurs
alors ça nous amène dans un deuxième
domaine dans lequel s'est invité ma
renaissance c'est celui des nouvelles
possibilités
des nouvelles opportunités alors
avoir frôlé la mort me donne le courage
de prendre complètement ma vie en main
tout à l'heure je vous ai dit que
j'étais préparateur mental et coach en
performance mais par facilité j'avais
accepté un travail salarié paralysé que
j'étais par la peur de ne pas être aimé
et la peur du manque
ma renaissance
fait voler en éclat toutes ces croyances
limitantes toutes ces fausses idées et
aujourd'hui et bien
je m'autorise à être l'homme que je suis
réellement
je m'autorise à faire ce que j'ai
réellement envie de faire et ce que j'ai
réellement envie de faire
et bien c'est grandir au côté des autres
alors je partage mon histoire pour
envoyer un peu d'espoir et un peu de
joie mais
je rêve d'être la personne que j'aurais
adoré avoir à mes côtés
quand j'étais au plus mal je veux être
un bon compagnon
et ça nous amène sur notre domaine dans
lequel s'est invité ma renaissance qui
est une spiritualité plus importante
alors la spiritualité c'est vaste ça
veut dire beaucoup de choses pour
certains une spiritualité plus
importante ça passe par une foi
religieuse plus forte chez moi c'est
passé par le besoin que j'ai eu de me
former à l'hypnose au yoga et de
m'intéresser à la numérologie toutes ces
choses pour le dirigeant
ultra cartésien que j'étais et qui était
complètement perché un peu farfelu même
et bien toutes ces choses sont devenues
essentielles par exemple l'hypnose me
permet de développer des ressources qui
sont en moi le yoga avec la respiration
et les postures me permet de réorienter
les énergies négatives pour qu'elle me
soit profite
je me suis rendu compte de la puissance
de notre cerveau
et de la force de la conscience
du pouvoir de la conscience
avec tout ça vous imaginez que ma vie a
beaucoup changé et avec elle ma capacité
à l'apprécier
j'ai eu le besoin de quitter la ville
pour la campagne enfin pour le bord de
l'océan parce que j'avais besoin de
vivre dans un cadre plus naturel au
milieu des éléments afin qu'ils
rechargent ma force vitale
et donc aujourd'hui
je suis tellement reconnaissant d'être
encore en vie
que tous les jours
plusieurs fois par jour
je prends le temps de la savourer vous
savez ces petits instants qui vous
procurent beaucoup de joie comme
contempler un lever ou un coucher de
soleil regardez le ciel les nuages
promener son chien en liberté dans la
nature jouer avec lui faire des câlins
des caresses marcher pieds nus
je suis vraiment
extrêmement reconnaissant d'être en vie
et
aujourd'hui
ça nous amène sur enfin ça nous amène
sur un autre domaine de ma renaissance
le dernier dont je vais vous parler qui
est celui d'une force personnelle plus
importante
il y a une citation de Bob Marley qui
est résume admirablement ce que j'ai
vécu Bob Marley a dit un jour on ne sait
pas à quel point on est fort jusqu'au
jour où être fort et la seule option
donc oui vivre une renaissance renfort
survivre renfort alors j'ai des jouets
tous les pronostics alors si j'y suis
parvenu c'est bien sûr grâce au travail
extraordinaire de tout le personnel
médical et paramédical et franchement je
les remercie c'est grâce à tous les
témoignages de soutien que j'ai reçu de
mon environnement personnel et
professionnel merci
et c'est grâce à l'accompagnement bien
sûr de ma famille merci mon cœur je
t'aime
mais
donc
si j'en suis si j'en suis arrivé si je
m'en suis sorti donc c'est bien sûr
grâce à tous ces gens mais pas que parce
que cette épreuve a été tellement dur
elle a été tellement longue que j'ai
trouvé des ressources qui étaient très
profondément enfouis en moi et dont je
n'avais même pas conscience
alors forcément oui aujourd'hui j'ai le
sentiment d'une force personnelle
plus importante
c'est un domaine dans lequel mon épouse
a joué un rôle central quand je la
remercie de son soutien inconditionnel
de la façon dont elle m'a épaulé elle me
répond que ce n'a été possible que parce
que j'ai fait preuve de volonté et de
courage elle a puisé sa force en moi et
visser vers ça moi j'ai retrouvé
confiance en moi grâce à elle et
ouais aujourd'hui je crois que la vie à
plein de dents je suis complètement
conscient de mes failles je suis
complètement conscient de mes faiblesses
et le petit Dimitri qui se cachait tout
le temps parce qu'il avait peur d'être
jugé et de ne pas être aimé à laisser sa
place à un homme qui a fait de sa
sensibilité de sa vulnérabilité et de
son sourire une force
peu importe qui que vous soyez que vous
soyez un homme ou une femme
peu importe votre âge peu importe vos
origines peu importe vos croyances et
peu importe l'événement que vous
traversez là maintenant si cet événement
est pour vous très difficile
le survivant que je suis à deux choses à
vous dire
la première c'est accueillir tout ce par
quoi la souffrance va vous faire passer
ce n'est pas vous et ça ne durera pas
ensuite vous êtes beaucoup plus fort que
vous ne le pensez une épreuve n'est pas
une condamnation à vie et une épreuve
peut vous permettre de mener une
existence plus épanouissante et plus
authentique sans cette accident de
parachutisme je serai mort
idiot et content de moi
prenez vraiment soin de vous prenez soin
de ce que vous aimez merci beaucoup de
m'avoir écouté
forcément
[Applaudissements]